♪♪
Whoa!
Mega city.
♪♪
This is the place.
(Doorbell rings)
Delivery from re-bot.
Yes!
It's here. Thank you mister.
Hey, are you a boy, or a robot?
Both. I'm a boy-robot.
Whoa. Wanna play?
Yes, please.
3-2-1!
Why do people play games?
We play games 'cause it's fun.
♪♪
Fun? Never heard of it.
You've never heard of fun?
Oh wow, oh boy, oh man, oh
dear, oh wow!
I'll show ya.
♪♪
If robots want to know
something, we just plug in
and find out.
♪♪
Sure you can plug in...
...But there are some things you
can only learn by doing.
♪♪
Look...
...with your imagination.
♪♪
I don't think I have that app.
How do I download it?
(Giggles)
♪♪
Oh yeah!
You brilliant bot!
Woohoo!
♪♪
Unplug and follow me.
Woohoo!
♪♪
Wait!
How could you not tell me you
had a jetpack?
We're totally playing with that
next time.